Speaker 1: I want to talk a little bit more
about Steve Doocy.
Steve Doocy is one of the three hosts of the
fox news morning show fox and friends alongside
alongside ainsley earhardt and brian kilmeade
and steve doocy over the last couple of weeks
has had a few sort of off script sane moments
where he will interject some reality into
the propaganda that his fox and friends and
his co-hosts don't really seem to like it.
Earlier this week I played for you a clip
of Steve Doocy trying to explain to his co-hosts,
Hey, you know, there is this thing called
the the crime fraud exception in the law.
And if you understand it, you understand a
lot of what's going on with these 34 felony
counts against Donald Trump.
And his co-host did not like it.
Steve Doocy went off script again when he
pointed out Trump really shouldn't be talking
about the judge's family and the prosecutor
or the judge on social media.
It's really not appropriate to be doing that.
And Brian KILMEADE, again, just kind of rolls
his eyes and says, Oh, Trump, It was a really
great speech that Trump gave.
Something is up with Steve Doocy, and he seems
to be trying.
God bless him.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: And one of the last speak and one
of the point before we go, one of the last
things that Lucas reported on this morning
is prosecutors yesterday during the indictment
brought up to Trump and his team the threatening
post that Donald Trump made.
He posted on true social.
There would be death and destruction would
follow if he were charged and the judge warned
him and his attorneys, make sure that doesn't
happen.
6 hours later, at Mar a Lago, the judge was
attacked, the judge's wife and the judge's
daughter.
The judge's daughter wound up on true social
and a bunch of social media sites yesterday
because she works for a consulting firm that
did work for Hunter, rather, Hunter Biden
for the Biden-Harris.
Speaker 1: He's trying he's struggling with
a cough.
He's struggling to read his notes.
He's mixing up names, but he's trying he's
saying Trump was told, don't go after you,
don't don't do these inflammatory posts.
And then he's attacking the judge, the judge's
family and the prosecutor.
And and Brian KILMEADE is not pleased with
this campaign.
Speaker 2: If you go on their website, we
were scrolling through yesterday, they they
represent a lot of Democrats.
A lot of Democrats.
Speaker 4: Would say this is a very bad look
to attack the family.
He said these he just mentioned that they
are attack Alvin Briggs attacking him.
His wife posted something negative about him
and the daughter works for Democrats.
Speaker 1: So, see, Brian KILMEADE says it's
fine.
Speaker 4: Oh, there seems to be an agenda.
He didn't say attack the family.
He mentioned them in his speech.
I thought the speech was tight last night.
Speaker 1: I think we all watched that speech
live.
It was a tight speech.
Trump rambled incoherently about his normal
list of grievances and seemed to be focused
rather than on the crimes that he has been
formally accused of on his other potential
crimes for which he's not yet been accused,
and then abruptly wrapped it up by saying
Make America Great again, even though the
country's under a dark cloud, not exactly
a hate speech.
Speaker 4: Believe how tight he was to.
Speaker 2: A lot of support.
Speaker 4: It seems like bum, bum, bum.
This one.
I'm doing this.
We're going here's the problem with our country.
Got to run.
Speaker 2: And I like that he did it in Florida.
He's like, I'm getting the heck out of New
York.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
They're sitting in New York, by the way, as
they say.
The good thing he got the hell out of here.
This place sucks.
So listen, I don't I don't know what's going
on with Steve Doocy.
It really is.
I'm not speculating that.
Oh, he has seen the light or he hasn't, but
he's pretending because of this reason or
that reason or someone's in his ear.
I don't have any speculation as to what's
going on.
What I can tell you is what I see three or
four times over the last several weeks and
twice this week, Steve Doocy has tried to
introduce some reality, some cogent analysis
of the real world to his co-hosts.
And they just basically steamroll right over
it and say everything's fine.
Trump's speech was tired.
He wasn't really threatening.
He was just mentioning, Oh, all these people
who are against me are biased and on and on.
There might be some story here which you'll
remember with Shepard Smith at Fox News, you
started to see little bits and pieces of this
inkling that something was not there was trouble
in paradise, so to speak.
And next thing you knew, Shep was gone from
Fox News.
I don't know what's up with steve doocy.
His son also works peter doocy for fox news,
but it is certainly interesting to see.